we were never fashion people you know we
come from kind of this middle class
backgrounds never thought oh I'm gonna
be a fashion designer I'm going to you
know build a company around this
I have a memory of the suits I wore
before I was interested in wearing a
suit I mean renting a suit for
homecoming and thinking why do the
stones look so good in a suit back in
the sixties when we moved to New York
City
Williamsburg felt like a neighborhood
just littered with guys and rock bands
and torn jeans on their way to band
practice and those guys very much like
myself got to a point in life where they
wanted to and needed to dress up a
little bit more at first it was like I
know I need a suit and the suits that I
see on the rack are just terrible that
kind of got me thinking well I
understand to go and make it myself
borrowing Brenna's old sewing machine
that she had from high school led me to
figuring it out you know on the on the
dinner table summer making suits yeah I
became kind of an obsession and then
before too long I was making stuff for
friends and friends of friends there's
so many excuses to not fully commit to
it that was where Brenna came in and
said well let's do this I think you said
after six months so I gave you a year we
had you know a savings that we could
completely diminish you know we were
afraid and we had things to lose at that
point but we opened an Etsy shop so we
put some things up online and instantly
it got picked up
it happened so quickly from there I just
kept growing and growing and after a
couple of years we opened up the store
broken tailors so it's a mom-and-pop
shop and we never want to lose that
take this thing out for a spin you know
one thing I've always hated as a shopper
is is feeling you're supposed to be
intimidated by a space or by the
salespeople or by the clothes you know
we want to put the Welcome out out for
anyone and everyone
now I should sort of you know sort of
you it's like you're swimming in fabric
yeah we have our ready-to-wear
collection which you can shop for at our
store or places like Barney's on the
other end we have our bespoke
service making something fully
customized customs about building it to
your body and that means not just going
bigger or smaller all over it means
giving you a room where you need it
really the big part of our job and a
bespoke fitting is analysing each
person's shape their posture and I can
see that your right hand is hanging a
little bit lower than your left so we're
gonna actually cut this shoulder at a
different angle than this shoulder
and these are things you just simply
can't address once a garment is
completed you can't alter it and some of
those things that really just you know
make it click
I think the raw silk is it that sort of
lighter summery feeling is a better
option
menswear it becomes about the tiny
little details and about this fabric or
that fabric they're both navy blue but
is this the right drape this is the
right texture it's a stone wash with
bleaching
I mean guys are all about finding
clothes that fit really well ladies yeah
I think this works Buffy
doing broken tailors for the past five
years has been scary and stressful it's
been by far the hardest thing that we've
ever taken on in our lives
but the level of kind of pride and
satisfaction that we've gotten from it
is I mean I I would never go back these
changes have been positive we've you
know been able to keep things going for
so long and remain so happy we really
are very very happy despite never being
apart from each other we met in middle
school when I did finally ask her out to
break the tension a little bit I
actually said Brenda will you marry me
and she said yes here we are